[Musique]
à 22 ans Ligny Montin Clément Morichon
s'apprête à vivre une aventure hors du
commun avec son coéquipier Flavien
Castanet il s'élanceront pour l'édition
2023 du 4L Trophy mais avant le grand
départ l'heure est à la préparation pour
Clément je suis en train de préparer le
4L Trophy donc là c'est tout le matériel
que je vais emmener pour si jamais j'ai
un pépin mécanique chose que j'espère
d'univera jamais mais donc du coup voilà
je mets tous nos classes c'est tout ce
qui va être côté sécurité la course se
déroulant dans le désert l'équipement de
sécurité et d'entretien du véhicule et
primordial du coup c'est extincteur donc
ça c'est les lampes de détresse si
jamais je suis perdu dans le dans le
désert et après donc une batterie de
rechange si j'ai un accident le triangle
mon matériel c'est jamais j'ai besoin de
faire de la mécanique sur sur la 4L
après ici on va avoir tous les produits
d'entretien et pour faire la mécanique
l'équipe de refroidissement qui est
super important dans le désert
et puis après ici ça va être toutes les
parties mécaniques donc là ça va être
tout ce qui va être système de
refroidissement les pales de ventilateur
les durites une fois le contrôle de
l'inventaire fait petit tour du côté de
la voiture donc là du coup la voiture
elle date de 1984 c'est une fourgonnette
F6
1100 cm cube c'est un moteur Cléon donc
radiateur à l'avant et donc du coup bah
là on a moi sur ce moteur là j'ai
surtout touché à tout ce qui est donc du
coup carburateur et allumeur mais pour
la faire démarrer l'étudiant a dû se
mettre à la mécanique je n'y connaissais
rien du tout au début c'est vraiment
j'ai tout appris sur Youtube c'est ça un
peu la force de notre génération
maintenant c'est que tu peux tout
regarder tout apprendre sur sur Youtube
et sur les forums tout ça l'équipage a
également du aménager le véhicule qui va
aussi être le lieu de vie pendant la
course du coup ce qu'il faut savoir
derrière c'est qu'on a fait donc du coup
un aménagement on a refait toute la
menuiserie à l'intérieur donc là en fait
là ça va être ça va nous permettre de
dormir dessus donc en avançant un petit
peu les sièges je peux baisser la plaque
j'ai un mètre 75 pour pouvoir dormir en
dessous
exactement la chambre à coucher après il
manque juste un petit matelas pour pour
être tranquille et après en dessous donc
là ici j'aurai des baquets donc que je
suis en train de préparer là on aura
deux grands tiroirs pour mettre mes
pièces mécaniques ici
à côté on aura des petits paquets en
plastique pour nos vêtements et puis
tous les vivres qu'on aura besoin parmi
leurs équipements également de nombreux
sacs et fournitures seront distribués
dans les villages aux enfants
des sacs avec donc s'il y a pas de silo
faut que je mette des stylos et on
mettra des je vais mettre des cahiers
dedans agis - 1 avant le départ des 1200
voitures participantes l'objectif pour
le duo yvelinois est avant tout d'aller
au bout de l'aventure et de soutenir
l'association Les Enfants du désert